I see great danger for the human race
there have been a number of times in the
past when its survival has been a
question of touch-and-go the Cuban
Missile Crisis in 1963 was one of these
the frequency of such occasions is
likely to increase in the future we
shall need great care and judgment to
negotiate them all successfully but I'm
an optimist if we can avoid the matter
for the next two centuries our species
should be safe as we spread into space
if we are the only intelligent beings in
the galaxy we should make sure we
survive and continue but we are entering
an increasingly dangerous period of our
history our population and our use of
the finite resources of planet Earth are
growing exponentially along with our
technical ability to change the
environment for good or ill but our
genetic code still carries a selfish and
aggressive instincts that were a
survival advantage in the past it will
be difficult enough to avoid the matter
in the next hundred years let alone the
next thousand or million our only chance
of long-term survival is not the
Romanian we're looking on planet Earth
but to spread out into space we have
made remarkable progress in the last
hundred years but if we want to continue
beyond the next hundred years our future
is in space that is why I'm in favor of
manned or should I say person'd space
flight